[Música]
en su discurso por el aniversario de la
independencia de bolivia el presidente
luís arte prometió no descansar hasta
que se sancione a los responsables de la
crisis que en 2019 culminó con la salida
de evo morales- del poder un hecho que
el partido movimiento al socialismo
considera un golpe de estado sus
palabras fueron recibidas con abucheos
por la oposición
panamá y colombia acordaron reducir el
flujo de migrantes en sus naciones
lugares de paso de miles de personas que
transitan cada año hacia el norte del
continente tras una reunión de las
encargadas de asuntos exteriores de
ambos países se acordó también procesar
a las bandas criminales que se dedican a
la trata de personas en ambos lados de
la frontera
y el grupo talibán capturo la primera
capital de provincia desde que se
iniciaron los enfrentamientos por el
control de afganistán la onu advierte de
una posible carnicería mientras las
tropas internacionales se retiran del
país
nueva actualización de noticias en
france 24 gracias por acompañarnos hoy
marín a colorado iniciamos en bolivia
que presenció un polarizado discurso en
la asamblea legislativa con motivo del
aniversario de la independencia del país
el presidente luis arce se refirió a la
salida de evo morales- del poder como un
golpe de estado y aseguró que no
descansará hasta que los responsables
sean procesados la oposición lo
interrumpió alegando que en los comicios
de 2019 hubo fraude arte afirmó que sin
la resistencia del pueblo la democracia
no habría vuelto a bolivia sin ambas
medidas de lucha resistencia y
movilización instaladas en la conciencia
y la memoria larga de nuestros pueblos
la democracia no se habría recuperado y
el gobierno de facto hubiera continuado
en su afán de prorrogarse en el poder
utilizando la pandemia como pretexto
para seguir vulnerando derechos
panamá y colombia acordaron reducir el
flujo de migrantes entre ambas naciones
zonas de paso de miles de migrantes
durante una reunión en el
y centroamericano las cancilleres
panameña y colombiana también acordaron
procesar a las bandas criminales que se
dedican a la trata de personas el lunes
se espera un nuevo encuentro para
solucionar la crisis migratoria en la
frontera entre ambos países donde unas
diez mil personas esperan poder seguir
su tránsito hacia el norte del
continente
panamá estima que 49 mil migrantes ya
llegaron al país en lo que va del año el
16 por ciento de ellos niños o jóvenes
para llegar al territorio panameño
tuvieron que atravesar la peligrosa
selva del darién que separa a ambos
países este control del flujo de
personas requerirá de ayuda
internacional
panamá y colombia quieren montar un
frente común para atender somos ambos
países de paso de una migración que
realmente no busca refugio ni en panamá
ni en colombia entonces queremos
involucrar a todos aquellos actores
tanto los de origen o los que reciben
por primera vez como los de países de
destino para que juntos podemos
establecer los propios protocolos y
mecanismos de manera que el flujo sea
o sea seguro y tenga siempre un enfoque
humanitario el negocio infame de una red
de crimen organizado están traficando
con personas que están logrando se está
necesidad que tienen muchas personas de
encontrar un lugar de acogida un lugar
que les dé estabilidad un lugar donde
puedan levantar a sus hijos y en esta
materia lo que tiene que ver con el
crimen organizado
hemos acordado también que pondremos de
por medio el trabajo de ameripol el que
trabajo de interpol la inteligencia y
las autoridades judiciales que nos
permitan por supuesto judicial izar a
estas redes que pueden estar obviamente
lucrándose de esta necesidad humanitaria
en otros temas la economía de eeuu
parece estar resurgiendo el reporte de
la oficina de estadísticas laborales
confirmó la creación de 900 43.000
empleos en julio el presidente yo badén
que se abandonó lo abanderó como el
impulsor de la recuperación económica en
el país advirtió que el aumento de
contagios impulsado por la variante
y los movimientos antivacunas podrían
frenar este avance el informe es de
carolina loza león
la economía estadounidense vuelve a
regir el reporte del departamento del
trabajo que confirmó que 900 43.000
empleos fueron creados en julio generó
optimismo en la bolsa de valores además
de un descenso en la tasa del desempleo
que actualmente es del 5.4 por ciento la
cifra reportada este viernes excedió las
proyecciones de economistas que
estimaban 860 mil nuevos trabajos en
julio el presidente joe biden celebró lo
que es indiscutible ahora es esto el
plan de bailén está funcionando el plan
de bailén está generando resultados y el
plan de bailén está haciendo avanzar al
país somos ahora la primera
administración en la historia en sumar
empleos cada mes en los primeros seis
meses en el cargo y la primera en la
historia en sumar más de cuatro millones
de trabajos en sus primeros seis meses
first sex más el mandatario volvió a
referirse a la que llama la pandemia de
los no vacunados cuyas sombras se
extiende sobre eeuu el país registra las
mayores cifras de contagio de los
últimos seis meses para varios analistas
el avance de contagios debido a la
variante delta resulta preocupante
creo que existe preocupación por la
variante de él está en el horizonte no
podemos solo ver este reporte y decir
que constituye un progreso sustancial
necesitamos ver qué pasará los próximos
meses
las industrias hotelera y gastronómica
están en gran parte detrás del auge de
empleos con la reapertura los
empleadores subieron los salarios para
atraer empleados y aunque el crecimiento
económico dependerá del control del
virus
by then asegura que la variante delta no
logrará hacer un daño tan grande como el
visto en 2020 cuando se perdieron 22
millones de empleos entre marzo y abril
los bomberos que luchan contra el
incendio dixie que desde el 14 de julio
sigue activo en el norte de california
pudieron avanzar en las labores de
extinción gracias a un respiro en las
altas temperaturas el aumento de la
humedad en el aire también ayudó en las
tareas
dixie se ha convertido en el tercer
incendio más grande de la historia de
eeuu y deja a su paso más de 175.000
hectáreas calcinadas además del pico de
la temporada de incendios aún no ha
llegado si el fuego sigue adelante
california podría superar la cantidad de
superficie quemada el año pasado que fue
el peor en la historia del estado las
llamas redujeron a cenizas el icónico
pueblo de greenville fundado hace 150
años
y las llamas tampoco dan tregua a la
europa del mediterráneo oriental llevan
diez días de incendios consecutivos en
turquía y cuatro en grecia las
autoridades griegas tratan de controlar
el fuego que está activo en más de 150
focos en el país cientos han tenido que
ser evacuados y una persona falleció
grecia está sufriendo la peor ola de
calor en 30 años que hago me ha
alimentado las llamas en turquía la
situación es aún peor hay más de 200
incendios muchos ya ha bajo control pero
que han obligado a decenas de miles a
abandonar sus hogares y ha dejado al
menos 8 muertos el presidente turco
recep tayyp erdogán aseguró que son los
peores incendios de la historia del país
y entró en vigor en italia el llamado
pase verde obligatorio para ingresar a
restaurantes y lugares de ocio el país
adriático fue la primera nación europea
en obligar al personal sanitario a
vacunarse y aplicadas y disposiciones
parecidas a las que se impondrán a
partir de este lunes en francia en ambos
países la norma ha sido acogida por
muchos y criticada por otros informe de
rosa pérez masdéu y es necesario el pase
sanitario para hacer vida normal y
turismo en italia desde este viernes
para ingresar en bares restaurantes
cines gimnasios o museos es imperativo
presentar el llamado green pass o pase
verde un documento necesario para
acreditar la pauta de vacunación de
recuperación de la enfermedad o un test
cobit negativo reciente en la primera
jornada de vigencia la implementación
del pase sanitario se ha traducido en
cierta confusión tanto para residentes
como para turistas
nos pidieron el pase sanitario algunos
no lo tenían porque todavía no
recibieron la vacuna así que hemos
tomado cosas para llevar para muchos la
disposición es bienvenida como una
medida de protección que abertis ganó el
pase sanitario es un beneficio para
nosotros los dueños de restaurantes y
para los clientes es muy importante
porque entre más medidas tengamos
podremos manejar mejor la pandemia amob
esta pandemia desde que el gobierno
planteó la imposición del pase sanitario
cientos de personas contestaron la
medida en las calles calificándola de
liberticida y orientada a la práctica a
obligar a la población a vacunarse
lo que opino es que esta medida es
necesaria a día de hoy la provisión de
un estado bio securitario donde tienes
que certificar continuamente que no
estás enfermo es conforme a un estado de
derecho teniendo en cuenta que con la
vacuna evitamos síntomas graves pero no
el contagio cuál es el sentido del pase
sanitario
a partir del 1 de septiembre el pase
sanitario también será necesario para
usar el transporte público de larga
distancia en los centros educativos será
requerido al personal de educación
obligatoria y superior y estudiantes
universitarios los docentes que no lo
aporten serán suspendidos de actividad y
sueldo pasamos ahora a hablar del
conflicto entre el grupo talibán y el
gobierno afgano que empeora a medida que
avanza la salida de las tropas
internacionales este viernes los
insurgentes tomaron la primera capital
provincial en el país desde el
resurgimiento de la violencia además un
funcionario del gobierno afgano fue
asesinado por los talibanes en kabul la
onu por su parte alerta de que la guerra
en el país está entrando en su momento
más destructivo natale a plazas más
amplia en el siguiente informe
los talibanes ya tienen una primera
capital provincial en su dominio se
trata de la ciudad de sarán de la
provincia sureña de nimbus en afganistán
marcas de bruce y bobby rush está bajo
el control de los talibanes la oficina
del gobernador el jefe del complejo
policial y todos los distritos de la
ciudad han sido capturados por los
talibanes
es una victoria simbólica y un acto
desafiante de los insurgentes que tras
el retiro de las tropas internacionales
este año avanzan a pasos de gigante con
un solo objetivo en la mira el dominio
total del país la encarnizada lucha
contra las tropas del gobierno ha matado
a más de 1000 civiles en los últimos
meses miles más han sido desplazados o
están atrapados en ciudades sin poder
abandonar sus casas la onu advierte de
una carnicería
en las últimas semanas la guerra en
afganistán ha entrado en una nueva fase
más mortífera y destructiva la amenaza
de grandes áreas urbanas parece ser una
decisión estratégica de los talibanes
que han aceptado la probable carnicería
que se producirá
en el avance de los talibanes suscita
nerviosismo a nivel internacional como
reflejo de la atención rusia participó
en ejercicios militares en uzbekistán y
tayikistán dos países vecinos de
afganistán una manera de mostrar que
moscú no permitirá la inestabilidad en
su flanco sur
miembros de las fuerzas rebeldes de la
región de tigre en etiopía se tomaron la
ciudad de lalibela un lugar conocido por
sus iglesias excavadas en las rocas que
fueron declaradas patrimonio de la
humanidad por la unesco desde el
estallido de los combates en noviembre
de 2020 entre el ejército de etíopes y
los insurgentes el país africano vive
una crisis política social y alimentaria
que ha dificultado el ingreso de la
asistencia humanitaria el informe es de
andrea maya
lalibela en el norte de etiopía es un
lugar único en el mundo alberga 11
iglesias monolíticas talladas
enteramente en roca y que datan de los
siglos 11 y 12 es un lugar sagrado para
millones de cristianos ortodoxos etíopes
[Aplausos]
pero el conflicto en la región de tigres
se extendió a anjara región donde se
encuentra la nivela las fuerzas rebeldes
de la región de tigre se tomaron la
ciudad antigua provocando el
desplazamiento de unas 250.000 personas
y generando temores por el futuro de la
también conocida como la segunda
jerusalén which hold on hacemos un
llamado al frente de liberación popular
de tigre para proteger este patrimonio
cultural y a todas las partes del
conflicto para poner fin a la violencia
el conflicto en el norte de etiopía
estalló en noviembre de 2020 cuando el
gobierno central del país atacó al
frente de liberación popular de tigre
tras meses de intensos combates el
gobierno etíope declaró victoria luego
de haber retomado mekelle la capital de
tigre pero los soldados oficiales se
retiraron a finales de junio los
enfrentamientos han provocado una gran
crisis social y alimentaria
los suministros humanitarios que
incluyen comida otros artículos y
gasolina llegaron a mekelle la capital
de tigre nuestros colegas en el campo
aseguran que mientras la entrada de
suministros es un paso positivo la ayuda
aún es insuficiente con un estimado de
100 camiones que se necesitan
diariamente para asistir a 52 millones
de personas según un informe de la onu
que data de junio 55 millones de
habitantes de tigre están bajo condición
de inseguridad alimenticia de las cuales
2 millones están bajo un nivel de
emergencia grave y finalizamos en japón
donde 10 personas resultaron heridas
durante un apuñalamiento en el metro de
tokio sede de los juegos olímpicos que
terminan el domingo el atacante fue
capturado por la policía en una tienda
cercana cuando éste aseguró que era el
culpable y que estaba cansado de oír no
es habitual ver este tipo de sucesos en
japón un país con unos índices de
violencia muy bajo
y antes de despedirnos les recuerdo que
pueden seguir informándose en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom ahí
encontrarán ampliación de todas las
noticias de las que les hemos estado
hablando durante el día y además podrán
ver todos los programas que nuestros
periodistas preparan cada semana
hasta aquí este mesón de noticias sigan
con más en france24
[Música]